we have yet another one of Donald
Trump's cabinet members caught insulting
Donald Trump's intelligence back in
October you might remember I told you
the story of Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson calling Donald Trump a [ __ ]
that happened after a July 20th meeting
at the Pentagon according to multiple
senior Trump administration officials it
was never denied by Tillerson Tillerson
came out to deny other parts of the
reports like for example that he was
talked he had just recently been talked
out of resigning a Secretary of State
but he never actually denied what we now
know to have been an accurate allegation
that he called Trump a [ __ ] we now have
a new leak which tells us that at a
dinner with a tech CEO national security
adviser HR McMaster the guy who replaced
disgraced national security adviser
Michael Flynn McMaster allegedly said
that Donald Trump has the intelligence
of a kindergartner called him an idiot
and a dope
according to five sources with knowledge
of this conversation this was a dinner a
couple of months ago we're only now
learning about it but it was a dinner a
couple of months ago that involved HR
McMaster again the national security
adviser for Trump and the CEO of the
company Oracle the tech company Oracle
Safra Catz and as the story goes
McMaster was very blunt and in this
really upfront way just destroyed Trump
in front of her and what's hilarious
about this is that the behavior was
described by Katz herself as
jaw-dropping although she didn't
specifically say well he said
kindergartener or stupid or dope or
whatever the words were but you have the
Trump administration and some other
Oracle staffers denying it I quite
frankly don't believe the denials at
this point given the nine wait hold on
it's a 11 10 months at this point
actually almost 10 months to the day of
Donald Trump as president we've seen
these routines any number of times at
this point and by and large the
assertions of what was said end up being
true and the trend is that anyone who's
even remotely intelligent and I consider
HR McMaster to be a pretty intelligent
guy despite the fact that I would have
political disagreements with them
everybody who's reasonably intelligent
that gets close to Trump immediately
realizes that the guys just unfit to be
President of the United States and even
more interesting is that at this dinner
at the same dinner according to three
sources HR McMaster didn't just talk
what's that turn from fuses to talk bad
about Trump
he was also reportedly slamming
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
Secretary of Defense James Madison
Bannon at the time who was a White House
adviser and Donald Trump's son-in-law
Jared Kushner and there's a couple
takeaways here first it can't possibly
be surprising to any reasonable person
that anybody in this administration who
has a good head on their shoulders would
be mocking Trump in private right that
should come as absolutely no surprise to
anybody more interesting for me is that
there seem to be these rifts within
factions of the Trump administration
you've got McMaster and Tillerson who
both apparently questioned Trump's
intelligence which makes sense but then
you have McMaster being critical of
Tillerson as well we've heard that chief
of staff John Kelly has been concerned
about the involvement of Jared Kushner
so close to the President of the United
States that is the most interesting
element of this for me and the the sort
of bigger picture here that we're
building is that foreign leaders think
that Trump is a [ __ ] many members of
trumps own team think that the guy's
incompetent obviously my audience has
realized it from the beginning
so we're realizing that it is this group
of ideologically committed trumpets that
just revile the guy is some kind of
brilliant player of 4d chess some hero
but they are increasingly the only ones
who don't seem to get that the guy is
totally unfit but and this is where it
really gets concerning that might be
enough to get Trump reelected even if we
get Trump's approval rating down into
the low 30s as it's been or even with a
2 in front of it 29 28 % I've done the
math before that could still get Donald
Trump re-elected as president in 2020
and that's why as progressives we've got
to be activating at every
the most pressing one is December 12th
the special election where Roy Moore
might lose and we might have a Democrat
replacing Jeff Sessions in that vacated
Senate seat but we can't just look away
and say we don't have to worry because
the guy's obviously a [ __ ]
even with 30% approval those 30% can get
this guy reelected send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is made possible in part by live
linguae learning a new language is a
journey a long journey in many cases it
can be challenging but it is ultimately
one of the most rewarding experiences
that a person can have and for Black
Friday live lingua is offering a special
20% off deal on all live linguae gift
cards immersive learning with a native
speaker of the language is the most
effective way to actually get the level
of language proficient proficiency that
you want and live lingua is not offering
some kind of trendy new gimmick where
five minutes a day will make you fluent
in a month
it's the proven approach of getting
students fluent and confident in one of
the 11 most widely spoken languages in
the world and they use an immersive
language learning method the same method
that diplomats and educators have used
for hundreds of years but they do it
online so instead of driving somewhere
and paying for an expensive tutor you
save money and you work one-on-one via
Skype with your teacher meaning that you
don't have to worry about falling behind
the class and live lingua is inviting
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show to their Black Friday
special gift cards on Black Friday 20%
off at live linguae comm slash Pakman
that's PA que ma N and the best part
about this is that all new customers
will still get their first lesson for
free plus they can get 20% off a holiday
gift with the Black Friday gift cards
special they won't tell anyone if you
use the gift card on yourself that's
absolutely acceptable find out more at
Live lingua comm slash PA k &
a n2 get 20% off all gift card orders on
Black Friday